we have a story from timcast.com Kevin
Spacey acquitted of sexual assault
charges in London there's a lot for a
lot for me to process after what has
just happened today Spacey said he was
found not guilty of the nine sexual
assault charges filed against him in the
United Kingdom and the interesting thing
I'm seeing from the story is that there
are a lot of people I'm saying it's
split online they're saying we know he's
guilty anyway and there are other people
saying this proves the metoo moral Panic
was complete BS so what do you think is
Kevin Spacey guilty no matter what even
if the court found him not guilty
because I think there was one report
that he was on he was witnessed being
like on one of the planes with Epstein
or something like that or was he falsely
accused because of me too woke victim
culture my first thought is that he's
innocent until he's proven guilty and if
he wasn't proven guilty he's innocent
that's just the way our legal system
works apparently this was in the UK it
doesn't work like that in the UK I don't
know I don't know enough about the um
about the accusations against him so
it's kind of hard to say he grabbed a
bunch of dudes junk
I mean that's horrible if that's if that
is true should not have happened and
it's wrong so I I think it's hard it's
hard to kind of SP I I wouldn't
speculate myself just because I don't I
didn't I haven't studied the allegations
against him I do think that just because
something doesn't turn up a guilty
verdict in a court of law doesn't mean
the person's automatically innocent of
course they're innocent in terms of the
law but that doesn't mean in society
that's a good person to hang out with
necessarily so I think it depends on
what were the allegations and I'd have
to
study them to make any kind of opinion
that's a good point I'm not saying he
didn't do it it's different he's just
legally innocent right of course and
that's right
the court of law matters a lot I think
some of the people accuse him died right
I've heard that something like that
I do think this is part you know back to
what you were saying you know I think
you were kind of speaking to
um maybe a concern about
authoritarianism I'm very very
anti-government I I see it I think
there's a lot of wisdom to being wary of
a government getting too big and too
powerful so I think there's a lot of
wisdom to that but I'm speaking more
when I talk about you know sexual ethics
less about the government imposing
exactly whether or not you make sexual
mistakes I don't think that's even
possible right it's one thing to ban
pornographers from selling porn it's
another thing to you know have a camera
in every house to see are you looking at
porn that I would never say is the right
thing to do that's of abuse in and of
itself but I think the question that I'm
the more speaking to is what's the right
way for us to behave in a society what's
healthiest what's best what's the moral
path and you know the whole Kevin this
whole Kevin Spacey story unfortunately
whether or not he is the abuser you know
it's inconclusive it seems from Justice
headline we don't know I mean the court
found him you know not guilty I haven't
studied it is what I'm saying he's
innocent in this case obviously with the
court but there is a I would just say
all around Society there is chaos in
male female relationships I think we all
agree with that people are and there was
a Pew research that came out saying that
the large majority of people are unhappy
with dating most think dating is worse
today than it's ever been
um you know people you know a lot of
women feel objectified and then they're
objectifying themselves and normally
fans a lot of men feel like there's no
women to date that are good anymore so
there's total chaos and I would argue
that's because we've forgotten first
principles about the moral way to treat
each other that sex belongs within
marriage that sex can bring life into
the world so you should be prepared for
that and take responsibility for that
when we forget these first principles
then we open the door to all this chaos
and I think we're living the fruit of
the sexual Revolution which basically
uprooted all sexual mores and said as
long as there's consent you're good to
go whatever and I think that's brought a
lot of unhappiness and Brokenness today
I think that there's a lot of a lot of
Truth to the to your point there uh the
the role the gender roles the fact that
men and women don't have uh the clear
distinction as to what is a man's role
and what is a woman's role in
relationships nowadays I think is is
something that you're seeing the effects
like you said you're seeing the effects
inside I think you've got you've got a
lot and social uh socialization was a
huge element of marriage as well for
women who were mostly hanging out with
other women they want to have a husband
they can brag about to their friends and
they also want a good husband and men
not only want a good wife but they want
someone that they can be proud of and
both the men and women are like I feel
really good when people see who I'm with
well marriage is such a beautiful
institution and as a Catholic it's a
Sacrament you know it's such a beautiful
thing because it not only can bring new
life into the world and I think that is
the primary purpose of marriage is the
ability to bring life and some people
maybe are infertile with most people
they get that beautiful opportunity but
it also brings Harmony between the Sexes
where we're working in this beautiful
way in harmony together and we're a lot
we've lost Harmony in a lot of ways in
our culture like psychically deadened to
the harmony of nature yeah I don't know
why I think it's dietary personally it
could be a lot of stuff social media is
messing people up staring at computer
screens for more than two hours a day I
think if there's one thing that you
could do to change that I think getting
rid of no-fault divorce would have a
massive massive impact on uh on American
society I think that like the Knowles I
think it was Michael Knowles that said
like if like the way that him and his
wife were saying there will never be a
divorce because if there is a divorce
whoever proposes the divorce gives up
everything or something like that if the
uh yeah whoever proposes the divorce
should be saying look I'm giving I'll
give up everything not like I want a
divorce and I'm getting half of the
that's the prenup it just says anybody
who proposes a divorce
removes All rights to any claims and any
property and et cetera et cetera unless
I mean that might be good abuse or like
you know infidelity or something so one
of the old rules of that you could get a
divorce like I just I just think abolish
no fault no fault doors yeah I think
that I I think that getting rid of no
fault divorce would be because it would
be a good thing because nowadays people
do look at at marriage like I'm extra
serious yeah but or because I think
there are a lot I think that men might
think like that I don't think women
think of things like that I think that
they want to say they well they like the
I'm married kind of like Mystique that
goes with it um more than men would but
at the same at the same time there are
plenty of people that would get married
just for a tax crediting after last year
after Roe v Wade was overturned there
was all of these articles and we just
did a actually a satirical video at live
action about these articles but they
were from like Vox and these different
news companies about all these people
said my sex life is going to change
forever because Roe was overturned now
I'm gonna have to be really careful
about who I am wasn't it really funny
how the it was so it just left us women
were like we're gonna boycott sex right
and then concertos were like no wait
don't I mean but right but it just shows
like I mean first of all it is a fact
that abortion is backup contraception
and even the people who claim contrast
options stops abortions they know that
and they're lying the contraception only
increases the abortion rate ultimately
because it gives people this full sense
of security that oh I'm going to have
sex and you know I'm not ready for being
a parent I'm not even married I'm gonna
have sex oops I get pregnant okay well
abortion's my backup contraception
that's the way it's operating that's why
we have 2 500 abortions a day in this
country I would say more important even
than you know your your case for
abolishing no fault divorce if we
abolished abortion which is killing
people then it would change sexual
ethics it already is changing sexual
Ethics in places where even from the
people who say yeah changing my sexual
behavior places where abortion is
illegal my concern though is that people
do it in back alleys with the most
gruesome methodologies if we don't
change the culture's mentality before we
legislate that they can't do it anymore
we've got to do both because the law is
the teacher so that you know a lot of
women and a lot of men who are
pressuring for abortions if abortion's
not readily accessible they they many of
them don't have abortion so the law does
influence your behavior we know that
with seat belts you know when there's a
lot of wear a seat belt you wear the
seat belt back in the 80s no one I think
wore seat belts because there was no law
so the law was wrong
I'm from New Hampshire and we don't have
seat belt laws up there but I wear my
seatbelt we're in Virginia Safety First
yeah but but bottom line is the law does
matter but I agree with you I think
you're making a good point that the
culture matters a ton too and that's
where you know talking about this stuff
is so important and having open
conversations because I think a lot of
people I think ultimately we want love
you know like sex at the end yes you
know there's sexual gratification but
most people today I think deep down
people in general they want love they
want a loving relationship you know that
girl of your dream is that man of your
dreams they're not just looking for an
orgasm they're looking at the end of the
day for love and people who just hook up
ultimately feel empty in the end so
talking about how do we actually achieve
that well if you start putting sex back
into marriage and getting to know each
other before sleeping together like
really get to know each other really
understand is this someone I share
values with what I want to raise a
family with you know that would do so
much to improve relationships but how
what do you think about no fault divorce
are you would you be open to getting rid
of it you know what I'm torn because
first of all I would have to study a lot
more what the you know what the nuances
might be because I do think we have an
epidemic of abuse today
we do have a ton of abuse but that's not
nothing to do with no fault divorce if I
I agree abusing their spouse they can
get a divorced I I agree it's not caused
by no fault divorce I agree with that no
no no but abuse is Fault meaning I
understand abolish no fault divorce and
abuse occurs you get a divorce that it's
true in theory right but in practice
it's very tricky because in practice
proving abuse when it's he said she said
in a court of law can be very difficult
so I'm not saying we shouldn't get rid
of no fault divorce I'm very much uh
open to that because I do think we have
a divorce problem and we're just
divorcing for stupid reasons and I think
that's bad I think we're we're just I
want to follow my my dreams we weren't
compatible anymore and then there's
these beautiful children who are left in
the chaos of that and then we pretend
this there's no marriage
that's kind of how I felt like I got
murdered in their 20s there's no
commitment to that those part if at any
point you can just sign a paper and it
ceases to exist yeah
I mean I I agree that it's way too easy
to get to get in a divorce I agree with
that so I think there's maybe varying
degrees of what you mean by abolishing
no fault divorce but I agree that it's
too easy to divorce and too many people
do it too quickly absolutely that's
that's it's that simple well even more
importantly than even more importantly
than don't get married if you're just
going to quit on the marriage because I
think that's absolutely right I think we
also should be saying and this is very
controversial because this is not the
way people think today don't have sex if
you're not married and people when you
know a lot of people are like well you
know I remember telling I think it was
tough I don't think you're gonna win
that one because people will get married
just to have sex that's not a good thing
either well that too but I think you're
you're going to find
people are gonna bang you can't stop
them I mean people are always going to
do a lot of things right and but I think
Barney but I think it's more I do think
it's possible to have self-control I
think it is I think it's possible to
have a sexual attraction for someone and
not hook up with them but but that's
that's you right like the reason these
things exist is because humans do these
things that's it if it were a symbol to
say like people should have self-control
these things wouldn't exist they'd have
self-control but they don't want to they
they that that's why I brought up the
point about liberals ultimately just
downloading their brain their brains
into computers because they're chasing
carnal pleasure they don't care about
anything else they don't care for the
future they care about short-term
gratification that's it I do think you
can work on your behavior so I know
I don't drink anymore but like you you
you can't get someone that's doing
something whether it's detrimental to
themselves or not you can't get them to
do to change Behavior unless they want
to so like the the fundamental thing
that you're talking about of oh we need
to get people to change their behavior I
get it but you're dealing with people
that have a totally different
philosophical point of view from you and
and don't even start with they're repeat
like this this is something that I've
I've had to come to terms within the
past five or ten years or so but there
are people out there that whose starting
principles are so different they don't
even believe that you can engage in a
conversation honestly with another
person they believe it's all power games
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time